if you live in Gotham City chances are
at one point or another you're going to
be terrorized by Batman's greatest enemy
of all time no not loneliness we're
talking the Clown Prince of Crime
himself the Joker in Tim Burton's 1989
Batman Jack Napier aka the Joker is less
of an agent of chaos as he is a
psychotic Picasso I am the world's first
fully functioning homicidal artist so
what would it look like if Jack's Joker
had to stand trial in the real world for
his crimes to find out just what kind of
legal trouble the Joker would be looking
at we wanted to talk to someone
well-versed in the law we tried to reach
out to former District Attorney Harvey
Dent but for some reason he was
unavailable so instead we got the next
best thing
my name is Doug Ridley I'm a criminal
defense attorney I run my own law firm
and I started out my career as a
prosecutor in the District Attorney's
Office well Joker 89 does commit many
serious crimes in the film including
theft and outright murder we wanted to
focus on one criminal activity that sets
him apart from other versions of the
character this Joker knows how to bust a
move and priceless pieces of art as he D
faces the Gotham Museum art exhibit with
his squad of goons while rocking out to
the classic print soundtrack but what
kind of criminal charge does this level
of destruction actually incur and he
would be arrested for felony vandalism
it's vandalism and an amount over $1,000
which clearly with priceless works of
art he's going to definitely be on the
hook for that's a big party foul for the
party man
well the Joker isn't very subtle about
committing his acts of vandalism it's
unclear whether or not there are any
cameras in place to catch him in the act
or if he would have disabled them ahead
of time well it may seem pretty obvious
that he was still the culprit this could
end up working out to his advantage more
than you'd think what's interesting is
whether or not the police end up having
access to the same footage that we
watched I would argue if they didn't
have access to that footage who are
their witnesses in this sort of scenario
I think that just relying on the fact
that
a bunch of his buddies happen to have
spray-paint and vandalize the the
gallery there as a defense attorney I
would argue maybe lack of evidence lack
of proof of who it was that was doing
that if all we had was the fact that
Joker was here was written as his
defense attorney you can bet I'm gonna
argue that we don't know who actually
said that because any of his well
intended henchmen could have been the
person who wrote that with so many
co-conspirators involved in the
vandalism it's easy to think at least
one of them would eventually be caught
so what would happen if one of them
turned on mr. J if it meant less jail
time for them if one of the henchmen
makes a deal to with the prosecutor to
testify in the case and comes in and
starts talking about his involvement and
what he actually saw the Joker doing
well then I'm gonna tear him apart on
how much Joker gas he had that day and
whether or not he actually had the
ability to perceive and and and I
believe that my client would probably
sit there and make his grinning face and
hope that this guy trips up somewhere
along the line even though Jack's
criminal record clearly shows a history
of mental illness results a
psychological profile violent mood
swings highly intelligent emotionally
unstable it may be harder for him to
plead insanity than you'd think I think
that in the case of Jack Nicholson's
Joker he seems to be coming in knowing
full well that he is destroying things
and he knows that what he's doing is
wrong
Jack Nicholson's Joker just wants to
break stuff knows fully well that it's
wrong and embraces that wholeheartedly
so with his Joker it the intent elements
pretty easy to prove I think my only
hope is maybe he wasn't the one that did
it well other versions of the Joker Don
make up as a sort of Warpaint
this version of the Joker goes the
opposite way painting his bleached white
skin to appear more flesh-like and human
could this make him appear a bit more
normal to a jury if you were to take the
stand I would win too
be as normal as possible specifically
with Jack Nicholson's in joker 89 I
would put him in a business suit I would
have him have flesh colored makeup and I
would want him to be as absolutely
normal as possible if my defense in the
case is they can't really prove that it
was Joker then absolutely I'm going to
keep him right next to me looking sharp
next to his defense attorney who's doing
all the work because I would rely on the
insufficiency of the evidence in order
to get him a not guilty verdict so I
wouldn't want him to testify at all I'd
just be poking holes in their case today
there has never been a case of felony
vandalism in the United States as severe
as what the Joker does in this movie so
we don't have much to compare it to that
being said it's safe to assume this
high-profile trial would be the talk of
Gotham for weeks a trial for the
vandalism charge would last for several
weeks when we look at the footage for
that every one of those people that were
involved would potentially be called to
the stand depending on whether or not
all of his henchmen were co-defendants
or whether we had worked out deals or
something like that with some of them
potentially they might want to testify
the other element to any Joker trial is
going to be how long it's going to take
to pick a jury it takes a long time to
qualify a jury to find out who's maybe
read about this in the media to find out
who can be fair and impartial and so
it's going to take probably a good solid
week just to get a jury impaneled on a
case like that so all of their crimes
notwithstanding when it comes to just
the act of leaving priceless works of
art completely ruined and destroyed what
kind of sentence would Joker be looking
at purely for the charge of vandalism
unfortunately he wouldn't be looking at
the type of punishment that we would
really want for that kind of damage
our our statutes are limited as to
something like that with felony
vandalism as to how much we can get him
he's not looking at 20 years he's not
looking at life in prison you know he's
looking at probably best-case scenario a
good chunk of maybe a dozen years in
prison it's not a violent crime it's a
property crime there are some special
allegations that you can add to a case
that up the
punishment when the dollar amount is in
the priceless and the millions of
dollars worth of damage to vandalism
it's really an unprecedented case from
that perspective
very rarely do we have millions and
millions of dollars worth of vandalism
that's done at that point when I would
also do as a prosecutor is I would stack
each one of those up individually to
really try to maximize the amount of
time that I had for him in prison so I
would add each one of those and argue to
the judge that we have to consider each
one of them individually to get as many
years as prison as possible as I could
so it may not be a life sentence but at
least we know Jack won't be dancing with
the devil in the pale moonlight and the
streets of Gotham anytime soon bummer
those parades looked so fun
[Music]